Sylvester Stallone is pumped to be playing
John J. Rambo one last time, and that excitement
seems to be fueled by some new creative energy.
As he's done several times in recent months,
the star took to Instagram to share new images
and backstory text for his upcoming movie,
giving us a deeper insight into the iconic
character whose story he'll be closing out
with Rambo V: Last Blood.
Introduced in 1982's First Blood, Rambo was
never given much of a detailed history beyond
being a Green Beret, who, as you know, are
real badasses.
At the time, the fact that he was trained
to ignore pain, live off the land, and eat
things that would make a billy goat puke was
all the backstory that we needed.
But Sly's latest post, depicting the one-man
army as a fresh-faced young man not yet molded
into the ultimate killing machine, contained
some surprisingly specific details about Rambo's
time in the military.
It also alluded to the idea that for him,
war is more of a constant state of mind than
anything else.
A second photo, most likely taken on-set of
the movie, shows Sly in character as he's
either nursing a serious headache or about
to kill somebody, perhaps both.
The saga of Rambo was one of the more reliable
action franchises of the '80s, despite the
fact that First Blood was never intended to
launch a series.
The first flick was adapted from a novel of
the same name by David Morrell, in which a
mysterious, traumatized Vietnam vet is pursued
by police through the forests of the Northwest.
He's being chased down for the petty crime
of vagrancy, and the pursuit does not end
well for the police.
In the novel, Rambo ends the story by taking
his own life, a fate which was almost shared
by the character in the movie.
In fact, Stallone had to talk First Blood
director Ted Kotcheff into cutting poor Rambo
a break, altering the ending after the original
scene had been shot.
Although the film got mixed reviews, it cleaned
up at the box office.
For the sequel, 1985's Rambo: First Blood
Part II, the character transitioned from put-upon
anti-hero to full-on agent of death.
The follow-up saw Rambo returning to Vietnam
on a fact-finding mission, which eventually
evolved into a 1-versus-everyone gunfight
that seemed to involve the entire country.
That film also put up numbers at the box office,
rendering the name "Rambo" as shorthand for
"badass" for the rest of the decade and beyond.
"He thinks he's Rambo."
"Rambo is a p----."
1988's Rambo III moved the action to Afghanistan,
and seemingly served as an end to the series...
until 2008.
Two decades after Rambo III, Stallone returned
to work both sides of the camera in the simply-titled
Rambo.
The fourth movie saw our hero laying low,
minding his own business as a snake catcher
in Thailand before being forced back into
action to protect a group of missionaries
from corrupt Burmese soldiers.
While the movie's reviews were mixed, franchise
fans mostly found it to be a satisfactory
continuation of Rambo's story and were also
blown away by its insane level of bloody violence.
Now comes Rambo V. Throughout the production
of the series' final installment, Stallone
has popped up on Instagram to share set photos
that help sketch out the story.
Among those photos is a cowboy hat-sporting
Rambo looking intense in a rainstorm, another
with him riding a horse, an image of Rambo
and his bow and arrow, and a short series
highlighting the film's co-stars.
Helping to fill in some more details is the
movie's official synopsis, which helps to
explain the cowboy hat.
According to the summary, Rambo V will see
John Rambo living and working on a ranch in
Arizona.
But this is no pastoral life.
John's violent past has left him feeling deeply
troubled, suffering from PTSD.
When a longtime family friend informs him
that her granddaughter has gone missing in
Mexico, he sets off with her to locate the
young woman.
The journey leads him to uncover a ring of
sex-traffickers and kidnappers, led by a vicious
crime lord whom he must stop at all costs.
As we all know, being deeply troubled and
traumatized by combat has never kept Rambo
from bringing the pain in the past, and we
don't see any reason why this final outing
will be any different.
While no release date has been announced,
Rambo V is expected to hit screens sometime
in 2019, but just because it's the end of
the line for the Vietnam vet doesn't mean
it won't be fun to watch him draw Last Blood.
"It sounds like it's very depressing, but
it's not.
It's a kids' film!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel, and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.